alexa play eric rosen
alexa play eric rosen
shuffling songs by eric roberson oh wait
what
there's a roberson oh it's it's playing
um
look at this
look at this mr nice guy
[Music]
okay alexa quiet
huh anyway
thanks for the game let's move on
let's play one more again i'm getting a
little bit tired
it's been a long but fun stream
over two and a half hours so if you want
a game
this is the last chance to challenge me
i know there's opening requests
it's going to depend what color i am and
i'll see what openings i can play
oh tagging wants jio geo geo geo geo geo
we'll see we'll see but first
random challenge time oh
the forced bomb cloud
am i white i obviously i'm white but
it's my move oh so
i guess i'm i just have to i second the
g
g o g o g g o oh
we'll see we'll see
i know there's some geo fans here
what to do here
this is probably just objectively worse
for white
happy born cloud bits yeah okay
i mean if i'm forced to bong claw i
might as well
go along with it no idea what it is but
i thought the g o g o g
o g o g g yeah
what am i doing with my life
okay we're gonna pawn swarm we're gonna
let the king
lead the way or no we're going to have
the pawns lead the way but the king will
support the pawns
just an eric fan in general here i keep
purging the end of yours
lately ah yeah welcome brian
or maybe you've been here for for a bit
i don't know i hope it's been hard to
monitor chats
oh dear maybe i'll have to do like one
geo
at the end of this but okay there's
bigger priorities for now
the pawns must be pushed black was
threatening to take that was a very
devious
developing move
okay so we have
what is this it kind of feels like a
christmas tree
let's develop
oh
yeah i saw the threat of queen diggs g5
earlier
i guess i have queen h5 here again if i
take back i lose a pawn
i'll play queen here
yeah tis the season
[Music]
oh you sent me a dm on instagram oh
instagram is probably what in the eric
rosen is gio gio gio gio gio
oh um al no sabe
hey we traded queens guys it's geogessa
which i totally support
oh yeah you can't spell jeopardy without
geo
thank you alex i will say
um just a disclaimer
if you sent me a dm on instagram i get
i get probably a few dozen messages a
day
[Music]
so it's easy to overlook things but
i will try and at least acknowledge it
anyway um this is working out well the
pawn is
a pawn is making a climb
towards greatness
oh and thank you yeah i guess thank you
for all the geo bits and thank you alex
throws
a subbing for two months
did i i won connect four with g5
i kinda did at least by taking
oh what is this game should all kings
lead from the front
um maybe i don't know
miley cyrus the climb featuring pawns
alexa play
what the climb by miley cyrus
oh it's playing eric robertson alexa
stop it
hmm like c3
counter attacking a very tender pawn
i mean all i have to do is like queen
upon
but the night is in the way
[Music]
yeah there is a missed opportunity like
in this position black could take the
pawn
so i should be very grateful the pawn is
surviving straight up now geo me do you
wanna jio me forever
uh maybe wait
i don't know what that means i can't
accept things that i don't know what
they mean
to change the stafford gambit to the
rose and gambit
i love isn't there a website like
change.gov or no change
something change where you can like just
start a petition
maybe.org
i don't know how effective that would be
do we have to go to court or maybe i can
like make a patent
or trademark okay i took my wife's cc
cc
cc what's a cc stand for
chocolate croissant um
let's take a pawn no let's
let's play this first or chess club
or credit card maybe
or that thing you do in emails
as opposed to bcc
what are the odds my opponent tries to
check me for getting my pond and can
take diagonally
and capture promote
oh it's a fork okay i'm happy
very happy with this still waiting for
this move
doggie geotoggy geotagging
i feel like i'm gonna have to play like
one
one geo so i i learned earlier today
i learned a new scrabble word the word
i could type it here the word geoduck
geoduck is a valid scrabble word
and then on top of that there's another
pronunciation with a w for some reason
[Music]
g duck but maybe still pronounced
geoduck
i was really excited because i don't
usually like learn
new super weird words
then there's another pronunciation
without the k
like this is a valid word in scrabble
for some reason
anyway um i guess i should get geo lined
up
but first i'm going to have to promote a
pawn
oh dear duck
duck yeah uh
play c4 guido
wait what
oh dear g o g o g o g o g oh no ipod g o
g o g
o g o g i can't even for g o g o g
yeah i liked the part when you
said geo what's this there's jio
everywhere
i guess it's it's not gonna stop until i
actually play geo
okay let's go in with the knights i have
to find a new pawn to
turn into a queen
hmm
[Music]
it's not so simple
[Music]
but black is
black is still a little bit stuck here
let's play d3
no let's play knight c7 going after this
pawn
yeah as opposed to jif
oh wait if it's brown's gif
does that mean geo is pronounced geo
i don't know
or jeff
but in spanish it's pronounced
hiff i don't know
oh shout out to all the jeffs who are
watching
yeah except i don't think your name is
jeff
unless it is
oh really yeah there's a few like random
rosin center plaza type places
that's nice my name jeff
oh or maybe it's gaff
hey it's another fork
i'm giving you the last chance rosen
yeah so there's a funny move here if
king c7
i play knight a8 how does this dts
handle french words
bon voyage german
how do you say thank you in german
i thought it was danka in germany
also guten morgen
okay um yeah uh 98 is a cool move
because i saved the night knights
defended by the bishop
and there's no king d6 as this knights
up a beast
and just like mr beast and i would win
the bishop
okay yeah a lot of discussion between
pronunciation of g's and j's
anyway um it's time for geo yeah
i haven't done geo in a while i guess
people
people persuaded me or maybe just
brainwashed me with all these
tts messages so i am tired i'm gonna do
one maybe one round of geo
let me switch the title
i am convinced if we took the right
measures we can get it called the rosen
gambit
you are the one who made it popular in
modern times anyway
what wait what i don't know the
what the standard process is
what is this
wow that was a very abbreviated
pronunciation of
geo with so many o's
i think yeah you're beginning to break
the tts it's becoming lazier
anyway if you haven't seen geo
it's uh it's actually a fun game to kind
of play along with chat
and we're gonna do the i think i'll go
for the country challenge again
um the way it works we're put in a
random
place on google maps and
we have to figure out what country we're
in
i'll make myself a little bit smaller
just so we can see the compass
oh what language is this
is japanese i can't move
oh i forgot to change the settings i
can't move
it's japanese right
korean is more there's more circles in
korean
hi hi bombs 13.
yeah let's do let's do japan
so it's very rarely china
just in general because there's there's
little google maps in china
i thought it was like the geography
i don't think so unless there is a big
misunderstanding
could it be taiwan no
wait is this wait this is japanese i'm
trusting chat
oh it's wait
i think i'm gonna go with japan yeah
we're gonna trust akira lane
let's go first one down
or a streak of one
so time limit is two and a half minutes
uh number two
[Music]
hmm first impression is like
australia but
oh the car the cars are parked in like
weird ways
this car is misparked right
wait all the cars are like facing in
random directions
is that jesus i don't know
[Music]
let's find let's find words
oh could it be a mexico's interesting
guess
yeah south america i mean we're in kind
of an alleyway
type thing what kind of car is this
oh wait we can see oh we can see the
reflection of our google car
but of course google maps is going to be
in english that's so funny
it's a reflection so that's google maps
uh street view
oh license plate is yellow
something milk or mike's
so it's a hot it's a hot climate
probably
yeah the um yeah this is definitely not
australia
like mexico i feel like mexico is not a
bad guess or somewhere in
like south america
[Music]
oh there's a little like diamond type
type sign
yeah we could be could we be in like
puerto rico
but that's not even a country
that's a territory
cuba i really don't know
[Music]
what does chad think there's so little
time
and brazil is maybe like a safe guess
this this sky is all white ah okay we're
doing brazil
no colombia let's go colombia da was
peru
did anyone say peru
peru is like very mountainous thanks for
playing despite that
i set up for you oh my pleasure like i
am rated higher than i
actually am considering i lost to two
forks oh
how did you think i played
oh you played you played well
i think you just should have
was it this game
yeah you could have
taken the pawn better move
anyway i appreciate that
oh the tired bits yeah okay so ah
that was tough
i mean we got is columbia's a
neighboring country so that's something
i'll do one more one more
um
okay i'm thinking senegal
i think it's definitely somewhere in
africa
what's your geo rating we're about to
find out
oh again we see the street view
google.com
street view okay beautiful
um yeah we're definitely in africa
i don't know if we're gonna have much to
go off of
in terms of like text
i don't think we're in australia do you
study for geoguessa
um not really i just i've i've traveled
a lot i've played
i've played a decent amount um
[Music]
i'll occasionally watch there's a good
youtube channel a geo wizard
who's like there's some videos of this
guy who's like really really good at
this game
we hear some more words
yeah so senegal is the one
african country i've i've been to
[Music]
traveled there in
[Music]
february 2019.
um i'm gonna look for more clues
hmm
i'm not sure though
we're in like some kind of alley street
like side street type place
okay let's guess going senegal
let's go yeah we were in dakar zakar's a
main
like city
yeah um actually took a family trip
there
stayed in the island of uh
angora
actually do i have a picture i might
have a picture let me see
um
february 2019
oh here we go yeah so if you want to see
a picture
so here is here's a picture of me taking
the picture
so this is the island so we were on
[Music]
i think this like we had a nice airbnb
like
on the coast obviously
um so here is the picture
of the camera taking the sunset
this is taken with just a phone and
here's a the actual sunset
so it's nice the sky was very purple
and the the ocean wasn't too
threatening
and then yeah dakar is like the city
like the main city um
think it's the capital anyway
okay that was the first one let's go
number two or numero dos
we're in a spanish-speaking country
something oh a studio apartment
um okay well there's going to be clues
here
any flags
i'm getting kind of like south america
vibes
maybe like
i don't think we're in spain
[Music]
like maybe mexico
i'm going to have to maybe trust chad on
this one
okay parry
wait isn't par portuguese
or maybe it's just everywhere in south
america
okay any any more clues any flags
um
[Music]
i'm not sure is there a soccer t-shirt
yeah sometimes you can like look for the
sports teams
bilbao or no
they accept visa and mastercard
some people saying brazil and some
people saying
yeah wait where where is belle bilbao
bilbao is spain i thought
are we in spain this doesn't feel like
spain
it could be
there's no way this is spain but it says
bilbao
it's not spain oh we have so little time
let's go colombia
no let's go colombia i tried clicking
columbia
i clicked spain as like a safety guess
oh i tried i i really tried clicking
columbia
i've ran out of time though
oh i was gonna like make up for that
previous one
i'm so broken okay let's um
let's do one more play again
it's time we're going to do a speed run
20 seconds
yeah i got flagged 20 seconds last game
okay chad you have to be quick
remember remember remember okay doesn't
really help
wasser oh are we in germany this looks
german right
germany
people saying german how was austria
it was close germany is close by
good job to whoever said austria i think
there was at least one person there
oh jack jackie the alien
okay play again okay speed run
i have to get a streak of at least one
man this is tough
oh is are we in uh maybe philippines
it's a tuk-tuk or thailand
where's philippines
oh sri lanka
oh okay let's do one more
okay this one we better get wait what is
the
art petrol eric let's play one more
rosin
uh oh we're in wait what country we're
in some slavic
speaking maybe ukraine
how is serbia i'm not good at this
oh yeah let's play one more one more uno
mas
oh alexa oh israel okay
this is israel right
alexa quiet this is hebrew
i'd better be israel
who puts an email on a truck
let's go got israel let's go
okay now we can only go uphill from here
oh santiago
santiago chile right are we in chile
i mean santiago feels like a common name
of
stuff but okay
what does this say hey it was chile
let's go
okay saw santiago had to be chile
thank you man of polart for subbing with
prime for two months
okay we're at two let's go
oh it's mountainous kind of there's
garbage there's a hill
i have no idea
and there's no time
there's no time um somewhere in south
america
oh it was spain i don't even know what
i guess i guessed argentina
so i got i guessed a spanish-speaking
country at least
oh that was rough
okay well i hope people enjoyed it
for those of you that wanted geo
was taki was taggy here i didn't see
tagi tag was the one who started all the
geo
um the geo bits but i hope people
enjoyed it
like to do this occasionally
thanks and good night eric
oh yeah good night to
[Music]
good night to brian